[Music]
[Applause]
the pro football hall of famer
three-time super bowl champ mike is uh
nfl network analyst you can see him
special eight and a half hour edition of
nfl game day morning they start at 9 00
a.m eastern with uh rich eisen as we
make way for one of our favorites the
man who lights up the building is
michael irvin
he and
he and rich eisen never have the same
outfits on i will say that never
never never what's up baby never have
the same outfits on
thank you mike thank you mike hey
careful here
so long come on mike i haven't seen you
in so long
forever buddy i know it's a time-honored
tradition
having you having you at the super bowl
yeah and i'm so glad and i'm glad we're
back you know what i'm saying
been a couple years man huh yeah all
good we're back but it's all good man we
weathered the storm at least at least i
hope we have uh rich eisen said i should
ask you about tom brady's retirement
you're fired up about this
i'd be trying to tell these jokers man
you know that thing sounds great at
first
man i'm not going to come to practice i
can sit around the house you're not
going to be able to sit around the house
you're trading one box for another you
know what i'm saying are you joking
it took me forever i had to tell my lady
like hey you know i'm sitting around
when i first retired she's like what i'm
just chilling so well take out the
carpet
turn
i'm not putting these hands on garbage
these hands got us out of the damn
ghetto what are you talking about
trying to tell me to do stuff all day
tom has had one week of it one week my
bishop told me this would i retice this
huh
he said now that you're retired he said
i want to give you some good advice
what's that [ __ ] what's that what's
that big cause i called him daddy you
know it's my spiritual father i said
what's that bishop he says
work your way back into the house listen
what do you mean work my way i pay all
the bills yeah work your way the house
been running fine for the last 20 years
without you you got to work your so tom
is at that stage he just got home and
he's recognizing
man i got gotta work my way back into my
own house
you know what i'm saying over there i
was the boss over here i am being boast
man maybe maybe never say never you know
you start thinking about me
maybe going back never say never you
know imagine how he's gonna be in a
month from now that's what i'm telling
you i'm telling you so hey he's gonna
show up at the combine he's gonna all
those quarterbacks they better be ready
boy cause we got a great one on the
sideline in about a month he's gonna be
looking for a job i'm just telling you
right now
everything you think is not going to go
down that way you know you were just
king
now you just you just you just peon you
with the king over the campbell at home
you just pee on you do all the work did
you get depressed when you retired
i think everybody goes through a
depression if you want to call it a
depression or a re-identification now
you're re-identifying who are you you've
been this great football player and
everybody come and every time you came
around and cheered and now hey boy to
noise has completely stopped you trying
to figure out who the hell am i so so
that it truly is it truly is an
adjustment
and we'll talk about it you know tom has
a many many other things that he's
interested in and and all but but those
things don't don't don't grab you like
what you did you know what i'm saying
you try to find things that grab you
like that but i don't know if you ever
will what's kyler murray doing what's
his endgame i don't know
i don't know but we're we're in this new
time
and these young dudes now
you know they know
they have one god gave them this thing a
divine apparatus called a mouth gate
that's to speak with but since social
media runs everything they just speak
through their social media so he takes
all of the cardinals off his social
media which says to us
what the hell's going on you know what i
mean
we can't just sit here at
what we do we analyze and not wonder
what's going on and i'm telling you man
i'm telling you i think it's going on
all around all these top quarterbacks
are wanting they want their money so
they're negotiating you know they're
negotiating behind the scenes and these
these numbers are getting so high for
the salary cap that's why ann rogers is
going through it uh russell wilson's
going through it i think kyla murray is
already jumping out early and and going
through it and everybody will come out
and always say it's not about money dude
it's always about money and whatever
they tell you is not about money it's
about money
were you good in negotiating with jerry
jones and the cowboys
i i wouldn't say i was good i was in
there you know what i'm saying but this
dude's been no cliche billions of dollar
deal and i just came off you know
yeah the ghetto you know what i'm saying
so i don't want to say that i was good i
was in the room but i loved jerry for
always making me be in the room because
he knew that these nut the kind of
numbers that we were talking about i had
never even you know thought of coming
from where i was coming from so he was
trying to acclimate me he said michael
we're going to be talking about some
numbers i'm sure you've never
ever talked about but
a great point though mike is where you
came from right like if somebody said
you're gonna get paid a hundred thousand
dollars that was that was crazy money
you would have gone oh my god then all
of a sudden you realize
wait these guys getting this yeah right
there
they ain't gonna last
hey you're gonna pay me a hundred
thousand dollars to go catch i was doing
that for free anyway yeah well sort of
for free right you're at the u s come on
come on
get out of here come on
name imagine like no reach isaac it's
not we we we
we're with miami not michigan how much
that's going on in my head how much did
you get paid i stopped that man i don't
even remember that stuff what are you
talking about like i got a free
apartment
that was within the scholarship okay car
that's okay
what okay no i should have said what
kind of car what kind of car did you
my first car was my first car my brother
gave me that first car it was a little
toyota tercel i never forget the yellow
car and i told you guys this before and
it had you know the
the floorboard floor missing out of the
bottom and and my lady right now you
know my lady she was riding around
in the car and a shoe fell out
on the highway i said we're going to i
said
let me turn around and go get dead
we were hitting you know i had to park
on the side here dodge cars like they
defensive back grab that shoe and get
back to the sideline and put it on but
we went on to dinner man and it was a
big dinner it was a red lobster yeah so
that was a big dinner there you were
killing it i was killing it yeah yeah i
realized well i was
oh that was some good days man uh what
is jerry jones
getting at
he he keeps saying everything but
mike mccarthy this is your last year dan
quinn came back and he's going to be my
coach in waiting i mean it feels like
it's not even right now
and i i get on my boys because my boy
sean and rj down in uh dallas they they
interview jerry every friday i go on
with them every wednesday and i always
tell them i said stop starting stuff
you you guys start stuff you ask jerry a
question he says stuff and then it goes
nationally i got to be out here batting
it down on the national day you know uh
so every time jerry says
they all want to coach the cowboys
everybody everybody wants to be a head
coach every coach in the nfl wants to be
a head coach if he doesn't you should
not hire him that means he has no
aspiration how can he inspire others if
he's not inspired himself so you should
not hire him now that's just the reality
of it but jerry said i i'm dealing with
this how is it that you got both of your
coordinators back
both coordinators back
and at one point your offense was the
number one offense it finished the
number two offense in total and number
one in scoring
and you get both your defense was the
number one defense in takeaways and
people are out here saying
that man
you know the definition of insanity is
doing the same thing and expecting a
different like it's a bad thing that
they got both of their coordinators back
only when you're the dallas okay but if
you had that offense in that defense
then what are you missing
i have to look at the head coach the
coordinators did their jobs well there
are a lot of things that go on in the
course of a season injuries here one
thing here one thing there so it's not
just like okay we didn't win the super
bowl this year let's put a dynamite
stick to this thing and blow it all up
that doesn't make sense do you think
they underachieved this year
they won
12. wait wait wait wait wait look
dan
i am not in a courtroom you are not a
lawyer this is not a witness stand you
will give me a chance to answer these
questions that's what i'm telling you
i've had many caves in a witness stand
right here and it's not what i'm going
through right now
i know what that's like
and that's what i'm feeling like right
now i just don't you know what i'm
saying but but then no listen man
disappointing season
oh no doubt disappointing because you
did not win a playoff game okay but you
won 12 games you got to try the first
let's talk you got to try to first get
back to those 12 games so let's
duplicate that and then get in the
playoffs and do something different but
just getting those coordinators back
that was a great gift only
only around this country and only when
it's the dallas cowboys is that a bad
thing
yeah but that comes with the territory
they asked for this that you know
they're america's team that's what the
district attorney tried to say to me
it comes with a territory michael you
asked me i said no i did i didn't tell
y'all to come in that hotel room i was
fine by myself
he tried to tell me that's true too i
hate lying that's exactly what he tried
you know what i'm saying
mike hero walking 30 for 30.
okay i want you to get your plug in here
okay
you you you were eight and a half hour
show no no no no you don't don't you
have aren't you partnering with a uh new
media platform
i know i partnered with a lot of media
platforms jimmy's training crazing yeah
tracing about that that that's my oh
yeah absolutely now absolutely and and
and and and honestly and in this
platform it is about helping guys out
here then honestly sad part of what
we're talking about
and you're talking about the retired man
and even guys that are still playing the
sad part is
you're going to walk away from this game
and it's going to be difficult
don't make your life more difficult by
not having some finances at least so you
can try to mitigate the rest of your
life you're going to be dealing with
some issues and not having to get
opportunity to play let's not let's make
sure you're not dealing with the issues
uh of financial issues because you've
sacrificed and put a lot of work in and
there's a lot of things that are going
on out there you know
all of these new
everything coming in uh that we don't
understand i don't understand a lot of
these uh these
bitcoins all of this stuff coming in
crypto i wanted to play crypto all of
that cryptocurrency everything so i
wanted to partner with somebody to get
me an understanding of it so i can try
to
make sure that uh that we're all good
and i think i want to help everybody try
to be all good it's spelled
n t-r-a-d-e-z-i-n-g right
tradezing.com yes crazy uh barry sanders
coming up next yeah barry man i only see
barry this time of the year yeah which
is interesting i mean he goes into high
well you would never see him during
playoff time either
what wait did i say that i thought about
that yeah but but yeah you know i i i
i'm surprised barry gets this much run
at super bowl they've never been in
super bowl right no no no no
detroit uh let's give it up for uh the
playmaker michael irvin he did it
uh he'll be he'll be down the hall oh
yeah okay he'll run into it and what you
know this was a good 30 minute ride out
here man what
[Laughter]